hi everyone welcome to my talk and today
I will be presenting of Bastion
streaming the world of data science and
engineering so this sounds like a very
big title just try to cover everything
but what I hope through this talk is to
provide some introduction of vaginal
streaming from the perspective of data
scientists and their engineers so a
little bit about my background I'm a
data engineer at Capital One and before
that I did a fellowship at inside
engineering where I learned all those
bifida technologies and I got my
bachelor's and master's degree in
systems engineering from University of
Virginia to get started the first
question I want to answer it's always
bad when streaming so when there is one
analogy I really like is it try to
compare the water in the river as well
as let's try to come compare data as the
water in the river so batches as if you
deliver the water in a bucket to a user
while stream is you try to deliver the
water through a pipe so it's more
continuous so the first thing I want to
talk about is predictive modeling and
also what batching streaming means for
predictive modeling and later I will
transition into more of the engineering
perspective so the task we are trying to
do here is trying to predict whether a
given URL is a fishing website or not so
what is the fishing website basically
it's something that's actually like a
malicious but look like a real website
all we're trying to do is steal your
personal information so the example I
have here is you you have this facebook
login page but if you pay closer
attention to the URL you can see it's
actually some random URL and if you put
in your username and password it's
probably gotten to some bad guys and use
it for by readers so when you try to
train a model that predicts whether a
given URL is good
but you will perform some sort of
feature extraction
so basically features a set of thing
that describes your data set in our
problem it can be the length of the URL
and also maybe the age of the domain so
the longer the domain has been around
the more legit it is usually and also
whether there is a prefix in cervix
attached to your domain so when you try
to trim so the problem we're trying to
solve here is a classification problem
so you can use that logically regression
or random forest and the way you try to
trim your model usually just split to
the data you have for trainings and test
set and the iterates through through the
training process in the validation
process and then eventually you will
have a model and you can seek that model
to file so what that means is if you are
using Python as a pickle file if you're
using javac indirect approaches so after
you have your model you want to do your
prediction in a more traditional way you
can do your prediction in a batch or
offline fashion which means you have
more data points coming to your system
and every night or every week you run
your prediction use the model you're
trained and produce this outcome however
let's say for this project of the
fishing website you probably want it to
be more real-time you that's if you have
that email system you want to alert your
user ok this URL looks very sketchy
probably don't click on it and then you
will expect the case you probably deploy
your model in your streaming pipeline
and as the data company I will do the
prediction and have that the instant
output of that data point another thing
you will think about is for model
updating as your actual system keep
running you will receive more and more
data and then how you how would you want
to incorporate that data into your model
so you can gradually now offline fashion
which means that you retrieve your model
with your historical data and also the
new data you've got
you go from your system and then you do
that every like every night or every
week and sometimes this can be
challenging if your data set is too big
and alternatively you can use online
algorithms and also potentially do
online learning so basically for every
new observation continuous system if you
have a feedback for that URL for example
if a user flag this URL is actually bad
you can actually update your model right
away for that given data point and the
one of the advantage of this method is
you can attach to the new trend of the
data sooner and then there's some convex
middle ground is the batch or mini batch
basically let's say you wait for every
thousand observation then you update
your model with that so I have like a
quick demo about how online updating
will look like for you if you just let
say deploy an IU model does this like a
fifty fifty percent gasps but as the
online updating keep happening you can
see the model accuracy get improved so I
wanted to do a live demo but I have this
fear of like less demo that never works
so I just like recorded it just make
sure everyone has yet so basically what
happens I have this like um I have this
like a streaming system and then I have
this model deployed in streaming
pipeline and this is just like a
front-end that taught the accuracy of
the model and then the red line is the
accuracy of the model that of the
process that has the pre treat model
already and then the blue line is
accuracy of Python does you have a naive
model to start with and as model
accounting you do this online updating
so you server can see when it started
the accuracy for the naive model was
like points five point six but as more
and more DICOM like campaign the
accuracy actually exactly three three
nicely
so for this short demo I use them
sparks streaming so for spark 2.0 it has
this feature to save model to a file and
as we mentioned before we use the logic
tip secret regression for this
classification problem and you can train
a model and save your model and later on
when you want to do a prediction you can
load this model from file either for
your batch prediction or online
streaming and another part is this
online learning part basically you have
this update function that will call on
every RTD and then it will update your
model based on the new coming data so
couple takeaway for online hours and
there's always pros and cons to like
almost everything and so for our
algorithm is usually computational model
constitutionally much faster and also it
can be helpful when the data is too big
you can just update amalia in a small
chunk and also it adapts to new trend a
lot faster and if you do everything a
batch or like offline fashion however
the disadvantage of it is like majority
of algorithm themselves can only be
performed in batch and so online hours
myself is a separate research field that
people counting as their Tammy but we
will not talk too much about today
another thing you will need to think
about is for your feature extraction and
sometimes feature expression can be slow
and it will affect your ENIAC streaming
streaming process whether it's the
prediction or whether it's the model
updating so one example I put up here is
let's say there's IP address in your
data set and you are curious where this
actual location is at there may be some
external API you can call with this IP
and get a geolocation back however if
you use that as your feature then the
feature obstruction time is depend on
this external API but there are
definitely
anyways to walk her out there maybe you
can just pre-populate your database with
this IP and geolocation lookups so you
don't have to rely on this external
resource and sometimes if you don't have
any way to walk around look around that
you will need to think about well do I
really need that feature or maybe I can
just change this into some feature
that's faster another thing is it can be
hard to always get things right in
automatic way if you do online online
learning sometimes you have less control
of the data that goes into intial system
so you can't really like massage it and
play around with it and decide whether I
want to feed that into your model or not
it usually just goes into your model
however your team just said well we want
to we want everything your time we want
everything streaming whether because you
want more real time and auditioning
system or whether because the streaming
just looks so cool and everyone else is
doing it so you decide to do that but
just keep in mind um extremely cool it
can be a little challenging try to build
and maintain a streaming pipeline and
then you're curious why that's the case
so this is kind of them I'll first talk
about like what how to build a stream in
Python this is like a very bare minimum
streaming architecture basically you
have this queuing system that used up
the message that goes into a pipeline
and then you have this and streaming
processor in my demo I use the spark
streaming but it can be a storm or X
link so whatever you want to use and
then you will save the output of your
processor into a database here I use
radius radius it's basically data in
memory database and eventually you will
have your like consumer or like it can
either another API or like a front-end
that reach from your database of the
result produced I want to talk a little
bit more about Kostas orchestra is the
queuing system you can use other things
like missus but the reason you need a
cast out there is for a two meter the
two major reason when it does it acts as
a message buffer and sometimes for
example if the message doesn't come in
to assist them in evenly distributed
matter so this hour there's external
messages and the next hour there's only
a few so you won't like if you're
streaming processing processors do not
process them properly it's nice to have
this buffer so that like you can queue
up your messages and then your streaming
processor can pick it up later
and another thing ISM trust also keeps
lots of the messages which is nice um
this will be useful when let's say your
spark cluster just went down and then
you don't want your any of your messages
get lost because your cluster went down
so it's nice to have this letter record
that keep the caps in caps in cata when
you have another spark cluster that went
online you can just read from Glasgow
again and then just keep pretty
processing so then streaming pipeline
can be a challenging because of the make
the nature of the real stream itself on
events coming to pipeline usually
unordered so they can come all the way
in different order and also they're
always going to be duplicates for your
data data stream and another thing is
the data the real stream is invalid
which means there will always be new
data points counting so the nature of
the data stream makes you think about
how you would reasoning about about time
so there's two major concepts in in a
streaming pipeline one is event on one
of processing time so event time
basically is when this event actually
happens whether a user clicked something
on their mobile app or whether they
clicked this link on the website so
that's when this didn't actually happens
while processing time is when this event
arrived in your system and you actually
process it so we can see that sometimes
when event happens first it may actually
arrive in a system like later when so
because of that when you try to build a
streaming pipeline you will want you
will want to think about whether event
time matters to you or not here this is
kind of like a spectrum of like where
the event has been matter that much to
where the event times like matters um so
to from the first is that those
applications are I call them like time
agnostic basically you don't really care
when the thing happens but when they
happens you just need to know the
example I gave here is a capful one we
have this application call second log
one of the features is a call generous
tip so for example when you go to
restaurant you accidentally give like
50% of 50% of the bill as a tip maybe
you realize the waiter or maybe it's
like a mistake it can be nice you get
this notification right away from your
like a form like a text message or an
email so that you can correct that when
you are in the restaurant so in this use
case like you don't really care when
they then actually happen it's more
about okay when it's being arriving my
system I process it and they I send my
user and notification and something in
the in the middle ground is those
problems that you can use some sort of
approximation so let's say for a credit
card company you're curious okay what
are the top merchants my customers shop
at in the past hour so in this case you
probably don't need to get a 100%
accurate count it's more like okay maybe
I get a right even if
loyalty messages it won't affect my
outcome so in this you skate even if you
use processing time it wouldn't really
affect your outcome that much however
there also use case when event time
actually matters a lot
the example I give here is for second
look there is another feature called
double swipe basically sometimes
merchants will accidentally swipe your
credit card twice and the we will send
our user notification say ok take a look
at this again like that you activity is
this a mistake so in this use case event
times matters more imagine situation if
I went to a grocery store I bought a bag
of coffee 20 minutes later I'm like well
actually need another bath because I
just need a lot of coffee and I went
back there again but a little bath so
for the event time itself
there's 20 minutes in between but if the
first event that arrived in your system
a little bit delayed then the processing
time may not be that far away from each
other
so if you send user notifications based
on processing time it won't be that
accurate and then another thing that
event time is important is when you try
to do the deduplication of your pipe of
your data string so that duplicates
happens for all kinds of reasons but
when like when you try to DJ hit them
and you see the event content is pretty
much the same and the Estevan time is
also saying that's more likely to be a
bit duplicate so another thing you will
consider when you try to build a
streaming pipeline is the correctness of
message delivery so there are various
guarantees you can give when you have
this pipeline one is them so first is at
most once delivery so basically you
allow some potential data loss
it's like so when you have a pipeline
you have this kappa you have spark
streaming like when the message get
passed between them like
can you guarantee the message as you go
through from Kafka to spark streaming
it's like you mail a letter to your
friend and most once is if you mail them
once and you don't care whether they got
or not it will be great if they got it
if they don't that's okay
another real-world example is when you
send the video data from the through the
internet it's okay to lose couple like
of at video frame it probably wouldn't
affect your end users kind of experience
that much
another guarantee you can give is call
at least one so basically you allow some
potential duplications but you don't
want any message to get to get lost so
the picture on the right which is kind
of that illustration of that just keep
sending the information to your sure the
other end get does it gets it so it's
like a used by the same letter ten times
just to make sure your friend get one of
it the most ideal world is exactly once
delivery so basically you send an email
or you send a message as in the other
end like a receive it as in time however
exactly ones can be a little bit
challenging to implement it usually
requires a little more of better
configuration of your infrastructure so
one thing you want to make sure is
sometimes your machine fails like how
can you guarantee the consistency when a
new of machine comes up so couple
takeaways for why is it challenging to
have a streaming pipelines first is the
challenges come from the data stream
itself and how to how you want to handle
time usually depend a lot on your use
case and so when you work in a team for
both Podesta engineers in the science
scientists it's nice you communicate and
I think about what actually matters to
you so event time usually
like the real time war but can be a
little bit harder to implement because
for example if you want to do some
aggregation of the events happening in
15 minutes then it may require your
expert in minutes processing time
because some message may arrive in your
system with an available delay and then
the second is like there will be
challenges from your infrastructure
itself so how can you guarantee from one
system to another the message actually
goes through and then exactly once
delivery is very important for your
vertical results and you probably want
that for like its online online learning
process because you do want duplicated
data feature into your model and you
also to know long to lose like important
data points but overall streaming does
give you a more timely results however
also keep in mind that not everything
needs to be real-time one example I
think about is when you place in order
from Amazon Web sites like they don't
have to process it right away and ship
to you that right away
it's okay for them away to the end of
day and aggregate all the orders they
receive from one user so that they can
actually package up everything they want
and ship them in one time so just kind
of think about when you have a problem
whether you want to do it in batches
streaming just couple things to keep in
mind first is model updating batch
improves the accuracy every time you
retrieve your model online updating
actually can adapt to new data points as
they campaign it kind of ties to the
second point for latency and correctness
so batch definitely have higher latency
but you usually have a little bit more
control of the data of like what
actually goes into your training model
and then so streaming you have lower
latency that like the data can outcome
can comes up faster but you do have a
lot left in show
another thing I want to mention here is
monitoring so if you have a real-time
model that deployed you probably want to
monitor the accuracy of the model so
that every X something goes around let's
see your accuracy all of a sudden it
gets really low then you can actually go
back and take a look that PMI data
stream changed or is there something
wrong with my other model itself another
thing is the maintainability
of the pipeline so it is easier to
maintain one pattern rather than two so
if sometimes if you have a batch batch
pipeline and a streaming pac-man but
their functionality are sort of similar
it's actually nice to just do everything
a streaming fashion and if anyone's
interested there's their article song
like lambda architecture in the Kappa
architecture basically lambda
architecture is dispatch as this source
of choose and then stream streaming
pattern is kind of provide more real
championing along with the batch and
then eventually you will have a unified
results Cup however Kappa architecture
it only it only maintains streaming
architecture and batches kind of spilled
on top of the stream so I am a little
engineer myself but I always kind of a
passionate of bridge the gap between the
engineer and the data scientists and I
think it's important when the two group
of people who are closer together then
they will have they will come up with a
better solution so here this column
might take oh what's the difference
between data science and engineers so
they assign history or usually have a
better understanding of the data itself
whether like how to finalize features
how to get a label data and how to let
develop a model that can be used to
solve your problem well data engineers
they usually like more curious about
like oh how do I build this streaming
pipeline how do I guarantee this exactly
was delivery and also some middle ground
is like it can be like spark programming
and also like
whether event and more processing time
which one matters more so those account
discussions both groups will think about
and here are kind of a list of resources
of the things mentioned in my talk and I
have the colonizer okay happy ripple for
the small demo I have you can take a
look at you're curious of using spark
machine learning library to do this
online updating and and also the
settings that they desire self and the
following couple was our the reading
material if you're interested in
streaming and interesting how to build
like a streaming architecture on those
other things you can read about so this
wraps up my talk and I'll take some
questions
you mentioned that correctness is better
with batch than with screaming but you
have a spark processor right is within
that processor validate the right events
and discard the bad ones okay so you
could you like repeat your question
against language you mentioned that
correctness is a feature of batch but
not a streaming I will say correctness
you can have correctly is guarantee from
a streaming pipeline so this is exactly
one's delivery is where you actually
guarantee the correctness of your
streaming process okay yeah
any other questions so regarding deal
online training you mentioned only
certain algorithms support online
training right now I see in your example
if I recall correctly is a logistic
regression or something yeah so I just
out of curiosity just in addition to
logistic regression or what other
algorithms are exported and and also my
second question as I see you're using
spark streaming right well if I'm just
like using simple circular that does
that framework support any online
training at all yeah so um I'm not a
scientist answer from Rhyno
so besides a logical version I know like
a support vector machine that also have
this online algorithm but what it does
is this some optimum optimization method
you use so here you use this stochastic
gradient descent which you can like make
an improvement of your model for every
data points rather like a historically
you have this gradient descent that
change thing on every data points in
your data set so that's kind of what
makes it online which is you can act
upon every single data point in the West
that means that I think second and we'll
definitely have this stochastic
stochastic gradient descent are
implemented although I don't usually use
this so I can say for sure yeah just one
you mentioned don't mix and match for
the same functionality between batch and
stream that was towards the end of your
presentation and I forget how you put it
it was one good stream is better than
two yeah so the Linda Anacapa
architecture right so lambda is the one
Holland has two so the reason behind
that is if in lambda you have this patch
in streaming it does pretty much the
same thing but from an engineering
perspective it's really hard to maintain
you have that provision like your server
to do the same thing and you have to two
sets of servers that does exactly the
same thing
however couples using like a different
like alternative way it keeps all the
events coming as like an event log and
then you can do that in real time by
just consume the log right away or you
can do a batch session basically after
you have all those loves you really from
the very beginning and then connect all
data points together and perform this
batch process so actually my question
was going to be a capital one your your
goal is to get everything on a stream
right yeah we want you to do things in
scream like Sarah some yes on
applications sorry does it mean that
it's streaming you're directly
processing the raw data whereas if it is
bad you're collecting the raw data
somewhere and then processing it in
batches of time yes my understanding
that yes all right okay
all right any of the questions alright
thank you everyone
[Applause]